thank you good morning everybody and
welcome to
and today's um public engagement board
and there are apologies from the leader
and that is why you have me again in the
chair
and i think if we can just do some quick
introductions so that
um people who are watching the broadcast
and know who
soon who's speaking so my name is the
councillor
i'm a councillor ward and
i am the executive member for health
wellbeing and policies
george devlin chair of trafford vcse
collective and i'm a member of the
ccg board they member for patient and
public participation
thank you michael
i am a local councillor in altering him
for the green party
martin martin pritchard i'm the council
officer of trafford ccg
elena elena rope director of public
health for traffic
donna donna sega consultant in public
health at trafford council
hi i'm debbie walsh i'm the director of
integrated services the trafford local
care
organisation and that's mft and trafford
local authority
thank you tom
surveillance analyst for trafford
council
louise morning i'm louise wright sport
physical activity relationship manager
laura laura hobbs program lead for the
kovid team
huh
do you want to introduce yourself
okay we'll move on and andrew
andrew latham i'm the chief officer of
healthwatch in trafford thank you
tracy
hi i'm tracy clark i'm communications
and engagement specialist at
nhs traffic clinical commissioning group
and diane
hello i'm the director for a corporate
director for adults in traffic council
um i've got somebody with the initials
md i'm not sure who that is
is it martin yeah it's martin martin
dylan comes a marketing manager
for trafford council um
khan can't you want to try again yes yes
i'm just
late coming in han mogul i chair the
voice of bme clifford
okay um
[Music]
i think is that is that all done i think
that's done is it
i think is having difficulty logging
on so she'll um send her the invitation
all right well as people come on and if
they wish to speak if they can just
introduce themselves if they've missed
at the beginning
okay are there any declarations of
interest
and can we approve the minutes of the
last meeting
yeah thank you and um
obviously um eleanor you'll have a lot
more to tell us today won't you because
we can move on to item four with your
update you know
we're in tier i don't know we're in
lockdown aren't we from thursday so it'd
be really helpful
and if you can just sort of like tell us
what's been happening and where we're
going thank you very much
okay so um you'll have seen the data
report from last
um last week we've got a slightly
updated data set now
um the relative good news for trafford
is that our
again we seem to be slightly more well
plateauing again
but still at this very high level so the
concern my concern
is still as it was um when we met two
weeks ago
but i was very worried that we were
going to be heading up for over 500
100 000 by the end of the week and and
we're we're not
we're we're around about the 400 per
hundred thousand mark less is still
far too high particularly given that um
we have over 300 per hundred thousand
in our over 65 year olds and we we all
know that that's the population where we
we're going to see the highest risk
of serious illness so um this is
something that while we
are um hopefully we can start trying to
keep these
you know the lockdown will help us bring
these numbers down but i think the main
thing i wanted to talk about is that
again we are still seeing cases all over
trafford
every ward has more than 250 cases per
hundred thousand
and uh we have five awards at the moment
with more than
um five hundred cases per hundred
thousand and when i tell you where they
are they're david hume west longford
bowdoin hail barnes clifford so real
spread across the borough there is
nowhere in the borough
where we are not seeing huge numbers of
cases
and we're starting very sadly to start
seeing some outbreaks within our care
home sector
which is the sector that we had
absolutely wanted to try and make sure
we kept
and and people have been working so hard
to keep those
those people safe but i think once you
get the level of community transmission
that we're seeing
it becomes impossible to shield people
effectively
so we really this is something we really
need to be taking very very seriously
um we've got the lockdown coming in from
wednesday night thursday morning and i
think
my my plea to everybody in trafford is
really how can we help you
manage your lives over the next four
weeks
so that we can make this lockdown work
because if we don't engage with it if we
don't change our behaviors
we will not get through this without
further lockdowns
and we will not be able to list the
restrictions
as much as we want to as or as fast as
we want to particularly in the winter
so um and one of the things i was
reading at the weekend which i thought
was really
interesting is that it's about trust and
who we trust
and actually how trust because we always
trust our family and our friends most
don't we and we we think that our
families and our friends are going to be
the safest people
and they are for ev everything else but
not when it comes to an infectious
disease
with an infectious disease our families
and our friends are actually the people
we need to be the most cautious of
because of course it's an invisible
disease it's
it's um you can transmit it in the
asymptomatic phase when nobody knows
that you've got it or and you don't know
so it that not you know it's a clever
virus the way it works in that
it does mean that if you let your guard
down if you get close to people
you are putting yourself or them at risk
without meaning to
and the people we love the most the
people we trust the most are the people
that we are going to be the most relaxed
with
and it really is saying now is the time
to really think about
how do we protect ourselves how do we
protect the people we love
and how do we make sure that we can you
know really do
respect the fact that if we can reduce
the number of people we see
we will make a difference and it can't
it can't spread if we're not seeing
people
so absolutely make sure you do go out
for exercise meet that one person
um but keep that social distance look
after yourselves and your bubbles um
but really if you don't need to work if
you don't need to go into work
please don't go to work um work from
home
we're hoping that schools will stay open
i think that's incredibly important that
we do try and keep our schools open for
our children and their education
but at the moment it really is now we
have an opportunity to try and get on
top of this and let's
absolutely not waste this opportunity um
there will be lessons coming out to the
clinically extremely vulnerable group
they may not be quite the same group as
last time and we're still waiting to
find out exactly who's going to get
those lessons and
indeed what's going to be in the letters
um those lessons should be arriving with
people we've heard on wednesday
and it will be uh if you are in that
clinically extremely vulnerable group
i think the advice will be that if you
can't work from home you
you can't work um there will be
additional support and of course we've
got our community hubs in trafford and
they have been really really successful
have been an amazing amazing resource
and absolutely fabulous work from all of
our community groups and setting those
up
um so those will be operational we're
just looking at the
final details about how those whether
those need expanding and if so in what
ways
but in terms of actual answers to
everything um councillor slater i'm
afraid
we're still slightly in the dark we're
still waiting for more guidance to come
through
but i hope that's been a helpful summary
and it's really
really now it is in our hands to think
about how do we if your employer how do
you make
and you your business is staying open
how do you do that safely
if you're an employee or you run your
own business
um how do you manage that safely and
minimize your your contact how do you
can you do
the more you can from home and if you're
a parent
um how do you support your children to
maintain their education and again that
is about
limiting contacts with with outside that
education world
that's all i've got for now ah thank you
thank you for the um for the update and
ellen that's really interesting because
obviously
you know we've been i've been really
concerned about what was going to happen
with the
and clinically vulnerable uh especially
if it's not possible for them to work
from home so
it'll be really helpful to to get an
update from uh when that letter sort of
likes produced so
and thank you for that and and i just
wanted to ask
before i'm abusing the chair i'm sorry
i just wanted to ask one other thing and
i know it's really important that our
children stay
in school but do you think that and
there should be a consideration for
what's happening at universities and
colleges
and where we tend to have a quite um a
high spread do you think perhaps the
government should be looking to do
something with
with that group of people and are there
discussions around that
do you know so um i think
i suspect that there will be a lot more
online learning um we are seeing that
i mean the one group that we're seeing
the infection rate drop in
is that group of our university students
those sort of persons
first year students when they when they
all went back and they all tested
positive
so one of the things will be um i
suspect that they may be looking at how
they
manage the university teaching more
safely um but obviously it's very you
know
if you know if students are all um in
halls together and so on it does make it
much more difficult
i think the bigger issue so the in terms
of the
first years who would tend to be the
ones in halls um
it does look like the rates are really
going down there and that's been very
well managed by the universities
i think for the second third and third
years and the postgraduate students they
tend to live in
in shared houses and again for that
group it's really saying to them if you
are
if you are a student living in a shared
house please do take this seriously
please do make sure that you think about
yourselves think about your neighbors
um and that it's not necessarily you
know not everybody who gets it even if
they're young
um we do see people who are quite
seriously ill in
those age groups so it really is an
important important that you think about
that
and all of us are going to have to be
modifying our behavior but i do think of
course it's
it's much harder for younger people who
who are much more
you know who who do go out more um and
you know
it's really a really tough call for that
group so it is a plea with them
and i think a lot of them are behaving
very very responsibly
so it's a big thank you to those as well
because i think it's really impressive
that the numbers have been falling in
that age group so you know that is a
huge thank you
and some of the rest of us can
definitely learn from our younger people
thank you elena and i've
got council melton who wants to ask a
question if anybody else wants to ask
anything if you just raise your hand and
i'll bring you in thank you
michael uh just wondering if there's any
latest figures for hospitalization
and fatality rates from covert
i haven't got the latest figures to hand
but the hospitalization rates are going
up and we
and um inevitably
with the rates we've got in the in our
older people and across
yes we see those rates going up we will
start seeing the hospitalizations follow
but there is that time lag between the
people being ill
and the hospitalization um so
the reason for the lockdown is because
of the
uh and i know it's modeling but actually
at the moment we're above
the reasonable worst case modeling so
the reason for the lockdown is that if
we don't
stop the infections rising now we will
not
have hospital beds not just for not we
won't have hospital beds for covered
people we won't have hospital beds for
anyone
so it is really about making sure that
we we protect the nhs
by by and protect our need for the nhs
to make sure it's there for us
when we need it um through the winter
so again it's that please if you haven't
had your flu jab if you're waiting to um
do as soon as you get your invitation
for a flu job do please take your flu
job this
this year we really do we can absolutely
do without people ending up in hospital
with flu
um and the the the
um the inevitability really of some of
the people who are infected now and
tomorrow
and the next day ending up in hospital
in the months time
it's just real um just because there's a
time lag
doesn't mean it's not real
if we could uh if we could see these in
the um these figures
in the papers then that would be very
very useful because
elements yeah yeah what we can do as
well is i'm i'm keen that we put more on
the council website as well so we can
make sure that we
we link into that so that people have
that but we can send those around
definitely
yes they are on the on the traffic data
lab the only figures that i could find
were for
were for a couple of you know at least
two weeks out of dates
um and they i mean they show the number
of fatalities
in trafford at an extremely low level at
that you know at that point so you know
if people are going to
understand and see what the implications
are then
you know this needs to be clearer and
clearer and we need more up-to-date
figures
i'd take that point completely and we
will make sure that that more up-to-date
data is there
the other thing is that hopefully this
time we will see fewer fatalities
but um not at the rates if we can get
the infection rate down because the
treatment will be improving but of
course
treatment improving does mean people are
often in hospital for longer and again
that increases the the pressure on
hospital surfaces
but absolutely take your point and we
will put those figures out
thank you michael thank you elena and
nathan do you want to come in i can see
your andre
thank you for that i really just wanted
to double down
and i only found out last week that even
in search
of videos
it wouldn't be fast
people don't buy into the lot down
we're having a bit of difficulty hearing
you there's a lot of um background
noise in it so it's not coming through
very clear what you
you're asking so i don't know whether or
not you want to put the question in the
chat and eleanor will pick that up
and did you get any of it eleanor
because i i don't i couldn't
i was the question that we need to be
being clearer in our messaging about the
the fact that the nhs will run out of
capacity for everything
including so that any other things that
happen
um will struggle to be um done
so i think you're right i think that
messaging has been really difficult for
people to understand and i think it
hasn't been clearly made and the point
is
that we do need to make sure that people
understand
that we're not prioritizing covig cases
over other
forms of care at the moment is that the
people with kovid who end up in hospital
are very very ill they often have
breathing problems that
mean that they need those ventilator
beds and that means once those beds are
full
you can't do routine operations because
if you're doing routine operations you
have to make sure you've got the
capacity for people
coming around from the operation in case
for example people need
need um might you know something goes
well with some operations you will come
off them
into those beds anyway and then others
it's it's that insurance
if you like to make sure that if
something went wrong in the operation or
um that you
you have those those beds available um
so that is why the elective surgery gets
cancelled in
in these situations it's because you
have to have sufficient capacity
in your hospital to manage anything
going wrong
and that's why we trust our nhs so what
much and that's why we know it's such a
safe place to be
because they put all of those plans in
place now if those beds are already
being used by people who are acutely
ill the only thing you can do in that
situation
is um is cancel that elective work and
of course that does also mean this if
somebody has an emergency like a heart
attack
or there's a road traffic collision um
that person may then
not be able to be treated or have to be
transferred to a hospital
further away and obviously that's not
that's not what we want to see at all
so it is that when we talk about
hospital beds i think
people think you can get more beds well
it's not the beds it's obviously it's
the carers isn't it it's the doctors the
nurses the physios
everybody else in the hospital that does
the work
um to make sure that people are able to
be cared for
and and and so i think there has been a
misapprehension that we're prioritizing
covid
and we we have a choice but actually
we're not prioritizing covert
it's just that we know the people with
covert will need this sort of care
and if they need that sort of care then
we have to make
other things we'll have to give and the
only things that can ever give
are the things that you're planning to
do the elective surgeries
the hip replacements and so on because
it's much more difficult to stop
the the heart attacks the strokes and
the road traffic collisions
um immediately i mean obviously from
public health point of view
i would be saying now is the time to
reduce your risk of heart attack stroke
etc by
you know please now think about stopping
smoking think about your weight
take more physical activity be more
physically active that will reduce your
risk of the other things
but that may not get that may not help
us this winter
thank you elena and andrew i can see
your hand ray so if you want to come in
with your question please
yeah thank you i just wanted to ask
about
schools whilst i obviously understand
the importance of schools remaining open
i just wondered if there was any
evidence
to support there's a lot of discussion
on
public social media about the
correlation between the increase in
infection rates with
schools returning and certainly we're
seeing you know
one of my children was sent home to
because somebody in their class
um tested positive so i just wondered if
there's
any more that we could be doing with the
schools is there are there additional
measures that we can take to try and um
try and negate negate that
overall the school's risk isn't less
from the schools themselves because
they've done an awful lot of work on
this
and more i would say about some of the
behaviors that once you're
once the school is open there is more
mixing of people sort of
outside the school setting but helen i
think helen has been working very hard
with the schools and i know will want to
say something about this
hi yes sorry um so we sent a big cons
out it's what ellen has said really
we've
had very small numbers of schools where
there's been in-school transmissions so
either from an
adult to a child it appears to be
um community transmission and we've had
a number of schools where
um that's had quite an impact on the
school
i would say our schools are doing a
brilliant job they are
they have all the interventions in place
they're working really hard
they contact trace and react as soon as
they are made aware of anybody
who has tested positive or is
symptomatic
i think the issue is as elena said it's
um
children coming into school when parents
awaiting test results or other family
members are poorly
family party's still continuing there's
lots of behaviors where you just think
you know that behavior has knocked out a
whole bubble for the rest of the week
because of
of the the interaction with different
groups so we are working really hard
with our schools they're doing a great
job
and we've seen very small numbers of
transmissions within school itself
so i think that's all i could comment on
really eleanor but
but but we are you know really working
hard around communications and support
to our schools to keep them open because
it's so important
not just in terms of um covid but also
in terms of wider health and well-being
issues for our children and young people
thank you helen and if we can now move
on
because i've just noticed the time we
haven't got much longer and
thanks for that ellen and helena and
thanks for everybody for your questions
and
if we can move on to item five the um
ten point plan update and i think it's
going to be you laura isn't it
is it is it you laura
you've got an update yeah well i can do
yeah um
helen might be able to probably thank
you provided
no that's fine um i took the liberty of
having a week's leave as well so i'm
sure and
i'm sure helen collins and martin and
and others can kind of
contribute but i guess just in terms of
our kind of community engagement work
i think you know everything's continuing
as per usual so we've still got the same
work going on in terms of our business
bulletins going out and making sure that
there's clarity of messaging
and our cons team are working hard to to
to make sure that we've got all the
right information
um i guess it's a bit of a well not a
shame but we've kind of shifted haven't
we from a tiered system
now into kind of a full lockdown so i
think that simplifies things for us
greatly
um but but we're always kind of playing
catch up so
i guess we've now got kind of a four
week period to to do a bit of a lessons
learnt
exercise on how we were communicating
around the tiered system
and have a little think about perhaps if
we were to go back into that on the 2nd
of december
and how we make sure that we get that
clarity of messaging because i think
that was the real
kind of nuts and bolts of what we were
trying to do is try to explain how
things were different in manchester
um to to to other areas and what it
actually meant
um in terms of of tier three um
i know that that last week there was a
kind of a an engagement um
activity that took place around uh old
trafford and the public health team
did a kind of a voluntary session where
we had volunteers going out around
old trafford and outside of schools
trying to pass that messaging on
and some of the team went to talk to the
mosques
and it was good to hear that the mosques
are doing kind of lots of work
and again you know muscles are obviously
going to be be closed now for the next
um next four weeks or so
but really good feedback in terms of
their system reach and connectivity
um so some of them have radio systems
some of them don't but
kind of the main feedback there was that
actually they have most of the con
congregation on whatsapp messaging and
so i think 99
of the congregations are on whatsapp
messaging um
and they have youth volunteers which
have been stepped down but
we can kind of step those back up um a
bit of feedback in terms of how we need
to think about how we reach
uh females and children within that
community
um because obviously it's kind of mostly
mouths that
go um to the actual sessions and i think
moving into a full lockdown again with
mosques being closed i think it's how do
we kind of capitalize
on that what's that messaging um because
we won't
obviously be able to use the sermons and
things like things like that
um in terms of enforcement i think
it's it's a lot of the same really so um
i think our enforcement team
are dealing with kind of complaints from
bars not closing at 10 o'clock
um and i think the lion's share moving
into the next phase
is going to be around house parties and
and social gatherings
um there was a lot of work i think
around kind of border control and
enforcement of people
and the 14-day quarantine i guess as we
go into winter there'll be less around
that and more about kind of reflecting
on
um the national lockdown and how over
the next four weeks we get the
the kind of the messaging really clear
about the need to
um be safe really and and and not not be
having social gatherings in our in our
houses um there's probably going to be
less incentive to be outside in gardens
etc and so i think yeah good
opportunities for us to think about how
we kind of reflect on the last period
and our tiered system
moving into the december um but lots of
work still going on
we had a really helpful uh conversation
actually with kent and midway council
who have been developing like a
community community
uh champions program um and i guess just
linking back to what what eleanor said
really
one of the lessons learned there um was
about the effectiveness of messaging and
trust
and the feedback from um from the
council leaders there was that actually
there's a lot of trust with public
health professionals a lot of trustee
and community leaders
and a lot of trust with health
professionals in terms of messaging
and possibly less trust with just
council staff going out and passing that
messaging on
um but but you know again it's talking
about capacity because
i mean i know the public health team
were out last week trying to pass those
messages on in community set
settings but they're also trying to work
with schools and you know eleanor's
working really hard so it's kind of how
do we
how do we leverage your help i guess as
councillors and other sectors to make
sure that we have the right messaging
which we can provide but via you know
those kind of trusted
trusted professionals um and build that
capacity into the system
thanks laura and thanks for all the work
that people are doing
and getting those links within the
community to make sure that we are
keeping every residence
as safe as possible and i think that
obviously around the enforcement stuff i
think it
for the next meeting it'd be really
helpful if we could have a little bit
more information perhaps helen
could attend an update on that so um
i think you've done a and b there for us
so thank you for that laura does anybody
have any questions of laura
nope okay if we can then move on to
um um 5c which is the update on
escalations for the health and social
care
steering group so um tracy is that going
to be you
yes it is um tom's unavailable today
unfortunately so
he sent his apologies so it's really
only a short one from me it's a short
verbal
and because the health and social care
constant engagement
steering group haven't yet met they meet
monthly so
we usually meet after after our meeting
here today
so we will be meeting this week so it's
just um but some background work that's
happened
is that the commons and engagement
strategy which supports health and
social care and also the kobig 19 work
did go to health and wellbeing board the
last meeting
and and that was um recognized and
uh welcomed by them so they support that
facebook live
kovic 19 um question answer session
was held uh successfully with eleanor
roof
and our um our medical director as well
the ccg so that went really well we had
about 600 views
and there were about 40 people on so i
think that was something which was
really really keen
and again we are still in the background
doing some work around and
self-care week which is the 16 to the
22nd of november
and i think because of now the upcoming
lockdown
i think it would be really key to try
and get some um
key messages so if i work with public
health around some of those messages for
self-care week
and that will be for both the public
where we'll be doing tweets
but also for our workforce as well about
resilience and supporting people about
their well-being as well
so that's short and sweet from me today
thank you and tracy does anybody have a
question for tracy no
um i'm i'm aware that obviously this
month is a movember isn't it where we
look at men's health so i don't know
whether or not we want to have some of
that
messaging in um around you know stop
smoking and all those sort of things
for men to support to support their
well-being so i think that that
may be an opportunity for us and
anyway thank you thank you for that and
if we move on to item d
of the ten point plan it's an update
from the age well board
and i think that's from um you louise
isn't it
and i don't want to ask because i think
at the last meeting and we
talked about getting that messaging and
out over
and over the three-tier system have we
been able to
do that word for the over 65
i'll let you crack on sorry um
i guess in we're just at the moment
pulling together the
sort of something of a semblance of a
comms plan if you like with the key
messages so we've been linked into
um paul mcgarry at the aging hub in
manchester and we're looking at the
magnificent steppen as they've called it
in terms of the messages
um so counselor harding i know last week
had a meeting with
um a number of the hub leads to look at
how we can get the messages out through
the community hubs because i think we
felt that
they were going to be sort of the
crucial network if you like in terms of
getting some of those messages out
and also particularly um age uk trafford
and trafford carers
um are doing a lot in terms of
circulating messages
so apologies i was off also last week so
i haven't had a chance to catch up with
councillor harding on
some of the outcomes of that meeting but
we are
yeah there's just constant emails to and
fro about
age well bored and comms and things so
yeah
it's so easy that's really helpful and
obviously
next time we might have a little bit
more information so thank you for that
and if we can then please move on to
item
six and it's and trafford one one one
first implementations is that over to
you kathy oh no martin is it you
who is it is it cathy i saw your camera
come on martin so i assumed that you
wanted to speak
kathy sorry can you just give us an
update please
yes certainly thank you councillor
slater um so i sent through a
presentation i don't know if everybody's
managed to and have a look at it
so basically it was just to update
obviously on the changes in the traffic
general site for the urgent care centre
and the walking centre
obviously this is in response to covid
so it touches on the points that
elena raised previously about supporting
elective care
and the continuation of the elective
care work um just on slide two if you
don't mind just
moving it down um so and there are no
service changes for the urgent care
center or the walking center at trafford
general
so it's just to confirm there are
actually no service changes whatsoever
so those two services are still fully in
operation however
um in response to covid to ensure that
we keep the
traffic general site which has now been
designated as a green site
so what that means is it's been proposed
as a green site to support the stand-up
of elective
um care and the continuation of elective
care across greater manchester
so in order to support it and to make
sure it's as covered free as possible
we've introduced in line with the um
national campaign for
urgent and elective care that we
encourage patients to call
nhs 111 before they attend the urgent
care centre and the walking centre
at that point once they've called 1-1-1
if it's appropriate and they still
require a face-to-face
um assessment either at the urgent care
center or the walking centre
they will then get a clinical call back
within 20 minutes from our
local providers which are master core
and then they will be given a dedicated
time in which to attend
on-site so hopefully by putting those
measures in place we're trying to make
it as coveted free as possible giving
patients
appropriate and timely appointments at a
time that suits them
and also to ensure that we've got enough
um capacity within the exiting services
to be able to meet that demand so the
appointment system and enables us to
ensure we've got the right people in the
right place at the right times
to meet patients needs obviously we've
done a lot of communication behind the
scenes as i'm sure you can imagine with
patients to update them as what those
changes will look like
um and we that we will still expect
patients at times to walk
onto the site so if that does happen and
when patients do walk in
they will um be seen there's a triager
front end which is a senior level
um clinical triager he will then
obviously assess the patients in the
first instance for any covert type
symptoms and presentations and deal with
them accordingly either on-site in a
dedicated room or transfer them to our
hub clinic which is um based at
altringham hub
and if patients still require an
appointment so they will be then
triage clinically front end and either
um given an appointment at that time
based on how busy the department is
currently or asked to
um go away and come back at a dedicated
appointment time so we can ensure that
that
i'm sure you've all been but that very
small waiting room front end of the
traffic general site is as
socially distanced as possible so again
just to confirm there are no service
changes we are literally changing
how patients are accessing the service
and that's through one one one
clinical assessment and then giving an
appointment to attend on site
so we went live with um traffic the
traffic general site because
um of the green status to support them
to be um
continue with elective surgery the
intention is but
through the national program that that
will then also be rolled out across
manchester and trafford and obviously
it's a national campaign so every urgent
service will all be encouraging patients
to call one-on-one first before they
attend on site
obviously if it's a life or limb
thrusting condition
we would encourage patients absolutely
call 999 as you normally would do
but if it's not determined that you are
you know potentially having a heart
attack or you've lost a limb say for
example
that you would call 111 first and then
we'll be directed to the most
appropriate service based on what you're
actually presenting with
and so for the manchester hospital so
for mri with ensure they are going to go
live with calling 111 first before
patients attend a need this week
um and so therefore it will be a
consistent message across manchester and
trafford
we actually went live from the traffic
general site last tuesday
um to just support them more rapidly
turning that round so patients calling
one-on-one first
um initial feedback has been extremely
positive both from patients and also
from all the site
and the staff working on sites and
activity um
has dropped by half at the moment on
that traffic general site
within the first couple of days so
obviously we're doing as much as we can
to analyze the data to make sure you
know we're not losing patients anywhere
in the system
and ensuring that we're getting feedback
from patients on a regular basis
on a daily basis so that we can see how
it feels from a patient perspective
having those new changes
so in summary that's where we are
currently in traffic and obviously if
anybody'd like any questions more than
happy to answer them
thank you kathy and i just wanted to ask
a question and
i've had people who have been concerned
about people who may
attend if they are in mental health
crisis yes
so um obviously people are aware
of um traffic general and you're able to
just attend
if you're in if you're in crisis and
it's about what are we doing to be able
to
support somebody who turns up in it with
a mental health crisis
yeah and who who isn't able to ring one
one one first because
obviously they're quite corny so and if
you could just explain what that would
look like i think it'd be really helpful
i think it's really positive that you
know that traffic general is going to be
this
um kobe's free site and you know we're
going to be able to
undertake some you know some of those
surgeries that have been
outstanding for quite some time now for
residents but i
think if we can just understand a little
better around what it will happen if
somebody's in crisis thank you
of course yeah no problem at all so in
regards to mental health patients so
obviously
and we have the dedicated mental health
teams on site at trafford general and
that won't be changing
anybody who presents and doesn't call
111 and is presenting with a mental
health condition will be directly seen
as they normally would do by those
mental health teams on site
and also we put special measures in in
regards to one one one so if anybody is
predicted
and they do get through on the phone and
want to ring one-on-one they'll
automatically drop down
into the mental health dedicated support
line so that they have immediate access
rather than going through
a number of conversations before they
actually get the outcome that they need
to so
patients can walk in and be seen on site
immediately or they can obviously bring
one-on-one and do it through that
process but we've streamlined it for
mental health conditions so it's
um a quicker access for patients to
hopefully make it as seamless as
possible
thank you so much for that does anybody
else um have any questions or comments
thank you thank you kathy and the
presentation is really good and
you know i'll be sharing it amongst
colleagues so that people are aware
of what we're doing um at that hospital
site thank you brilliant thank you very
much
if we move on to um item seven and it's
the public engagement boards activity
is that you well enough
it's really for any if there is anything
i mean this one and
and the next item are really for any of
the board members to tell us about
things that either that they've been
doing
or that they would like us to provide
more support with so it's really to get
um the board members to tell us um what
else we we could be doing and also
whether there's any things that they've
been doing that they feel have been
particularly successful and we should
perhaps spread across the borough
thanks eleanor so we'll take um seven
and eight together then
does anybody wanna tell us about good
brilliant khan
[Music]
yes all i want to say is that really on
the behalf of all the
faith communities particularly they've
been taking this very very seriously
regarding their own congregations
because that is where a lot of people
gather and they've been
issuing out a lot of information to the
congregations
to keep the distance and also to make
sure they don't actually congregate
and i think this is going to be very
very challenging
uh to many of those people who go to
their churches and temples and mosques
on a regular basis and so really they
are learning something new
but for them this is nothing strange
because across the world
this is happening same thing is
happening so they are actually
looking at that from their television
programs and so on
so they know that they're not alone and
i think that they get
this reassurance that the authorities
are actually
ensuring that the support mechanism is
in place
thanks you
that's really um really good point
because i know that obviously
people have the chur you know the
churches the mosques
the temples etc have worked really hard
during this period of time so you know
we do need to be making sure that
we're doing what we need to do and learn
from some of the stuff that has been you
know that has been good practice
and i see that the church near me and
he's he's got facebook live service you
know so
people have had to um sort of like
modify how
how they are able to engage with um
their
their their people who attend the
services so
and i was quite i was quite surprised to
see because i haven't the governor at
that school as well it's saying auntie
instructed and i was quite surprised to
see father jed on facebook
but you know it works and people are
able to engage and get you know get the
support that they need from the faith so
i think that's you know it's really
important that we continue to do that
and is there anybody else that want to
tell us
yes just a bit of uh feedback really the
the
the workshops that public health have
been running for the voluntary
community sector i think they've been
really positive the feedback that i've
had is that people have found them
really useful
um and being able to follow up just
generally i think the support from
public health to the sector has been
really
useful positive and well appreciated
thank you george for that and we've got
another one tomorrow as well so
i think every time we have a session we
have a new scenario to talk through
so so their engagement and commitment is
really really value to us so thanks for
that
okay thank you and
thank you how do we advertise at those
taking place those workshops um we're
doing it through our colleague caroline
at thrive
so she sends that information out and
it's kind of like we do we do have
different groups at different meetings
so that's really helpful and
we're trying to do them during the day
and then later at the end of the day for
those colleagues who might be working
counselors later so it kind of like
tries to cover both really
that's brilliant thank you and honor and
is there anybody else that
wants to tell us what they've been doing
or tell us that um
we should be doing something differently
or if you can see elena's putting
comment and do you want to come in
eleanor on that it was just really to
say that we're very happy to do q and
a's with any group so if people do want
to
if people want to run that that we're
very happy to do that
i think um one of the things as well i
was just hearing um you know obviously
we've talked a lot about contact tracing
and um and testing and so on and i think
that the main things we need to be
saying is you know during the lockdown
obviously
if you are symptomatic do go for a test
but also
the contact tracing um quite often
you'll know yourself particularly in
lockdown who the people you might have
been in contact with
are and we know we've had such good
examples from again from our young
people about getting hold of people
themselves
so it's really to try and say to people
if you know who you
you've been in contact with just let
them know so that they can still
start self-isolating before they hear
from track and trace and so on
so it's really just thinking about what
we can all do to manage
manage things and get that back working
more quickly and more smoothly
i think in germany they're now relying
more on communities to do it than their
national
programme so it is thinking about in
trafford how do we
how do we do that and again i think it
comes back to the conversation we were
having earlier about trust
and you know if if we are able to do
that let's you know let's let's take
advantage of the fact that you know okay
our rates are really high i'm really
worried about them but actually
you know compared to the rest of greater
manchester we're now boston position
so let's try and keep that there and
work together to make sure we do that
and some of that will be if we can break
the trains of transmission really
quickly
and that means if you are identified and
you know somebody else who might
that you might have been in contact with
let them know and get them to
self-isolate as well really quickly
um because that will be really helpful
and i don't know donna's got brilliant
advice as well on remembering that basic
um household hygiene so donna i don't
know if you want to
bring that in now yeah i think um
as elena started off in a household it's
really quite difficult
isn't it to um to keep some
self-isolation but
um we were just and i've just been
talking to a family today and it's just
about making sure that
every single message that you have about
you know
changing your towels changing your um
linen keeping things very very clean you
know like if you'd have a terrible
outbreak of dmv in the home
you'd be really careful not to to let
anybody
mix and things like that so it's a
really infectious disease this um
and i think it's just keeping that
message about you know getting back to
basics about
always making sure everything is
scrupulously clean and i know
people are do it do that a lot but it's
a really important back to basic message
thank you donna it's really really
important message
the point that i'd like to just make is
that i think that we need to i don't
know how we do it but i think we need to
be clearer with people around if you've
got
symptoms you need to start yourself
isolation at that point
as opposed to waiting for a positive
test because i've heard of
you know from the job that i do outside
of the council is that
you know people have turned up to work
and then a few days
you know they've been in work and a few
days later that i've said oh i have a
positive
test and it's like well actually if you
have symptoms you need to be
self-isolating
at that point so i think if the more
that we can sort of like
drum that message home i think i think
it you know it's gonna
it's gonna save us lots of people being
out self-isolating because if you turn
up with symptoms somewhere you're just
gonna be spreading it and i just think
that
i don't know how we do it and i know
that we are i know that we are and i
know that the comms are really really
good but it's how do we actually make
people listen to it so
i do think that um if we can
continuously say to people
if you've got symptoms you need to
self-isolated
self self isolate and then get a test
and then you know do whatever you need
to do once you know track and trace or
whatever but i think it's
that message about sin you've got you've
got a continuous cough or you've lost
your sense of taste
stop self-isolating immediately so i
think that you know it's about getting
that message out
thanks thank you absolutely i i couldn't
couldn't react that's such a powerful
message and it and
it's also if somebody else in your
household has symptoms
and is waiting for a test please the
whole household has to self-isolate
because we've seen this several times
that and actually this has been
particularly around some of our schools
where somebody will have gone in while
other family members will have been
waiting for a test
and then suddenly they test positive as
well you've got a whole load of people
that are having to self-isolate so it is
really about thinking
you know even you know you might be
really keen to go into work or whatever
but actually or send your child to
school but actually while you're waiting
for the test
if you've got symptoms keep the whole
household at home because
everybody will be very very much happier
with you if you do that
um and don't end up with everybody else
having to be off
so it's really think think it think
ahead and think what would happen if it
comes back positive
because what we've had quite often is
people going for a test and then going
on
to work and then it becomes quite
positive and the people have said
oh i had really no idea i'm so surprised
because
i didn't have typical symptoms but
actually if you think
if you're worried enough to go for a
test then you must
must stay at home because um nothing
more embarrassing than going into work
and having to say
oops i shouldn't have been here
i think and i think we need to be making
sure that you know if people are saying
to their employer
and i've got symptoms that the employer
shouldn't be saying to people
or coming to work until we know you've
got a positive test i think that you
know we need to get that message correct
as well because
i know that there have been people on
the other job where
employer employees have been encouraged
to come in until they've had a positive
test and it's like actually
what you've done is you've made it worse
you know instead of just having one
social worker off you've got 10 off now
and you know we can't be in that sort of
crisis so
i do think it's really important that
that message is spot on and people just
you know abide by that symptoms stay at
home
that's what we need to be doing don't we
and
and we do have you know our
environmental health teams and other
teams will
will um provide support to employers and
businesses to make sure that they're
both covered secure but also
is really important that all our
businesses do abide by this and if
if any members of staff are feeling that
they're being pushed into going to work
you know
they they there are we we get quite a
few reports in
and we will do visits and so on to those
businesses if necessary
so it really is important that people
understand that we don't want to go down
the reinforcement route
but um at the same time we can't have
people being put at risk
so it's it's really important i think
all of this there is
there's particularly with lockdown
obviously there are laws behind this
and people will actually be breaking the
law with some of this we want to do this
by engagement but
at the end there is enforcement as well
and tracy just made a good point there
if we can encourage the testing centers
to be um actually saying to people
you've been for a test
you need to go home now and solve
isolate and if you know there are other
people
at home you need to be following the
rules so i think that's
if we can get that message now to just
to ask the people at a test center just
to reaffirm
and that that that guidance would be
brilliant
and thank you thank you everybody it's
been absolutely
you know i i do like coming on this
meeting because i do learn quite a lot
you know a lot of stuff and you know
it's really really helpful
and i haven't had any other business but
has anybody got anything that they would
like to say or have a question because
we do have a couple of
minutes left
no okay then and i'd like to say thank
you to everybody thank you to everybody
who's produced the reports and
thanks to everybody who's um watched
today and
and see you next time and i think you
may have me again so um you know
i'm on a roll on so thank you everybody
and see you all soon thank you bye